hola
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no no
[Música]
el otro día un amigo me invitó a cenar
quería que lo acompañara a conocer a
otras personas
presentarme a gente de su círculo y yo
que me encanta conocer gente de acepté
ya que estábamos ahí en la mesa
platicamos un poco de todo de viajes de
cine de música los temas que pláticas
con gente que no conoces
ya entrados un poco en calor uno de
ellos me pregunto oye y tú qué religión
tienes
y yo con la confianza que una pregunta
así me puede suscitar le contesté
fíjense que hace unos años leí un libro
científico muy interesante que me gustó
mucho que me permite afirmar
sin miedo a equivocarme que dios no
existe
se hizo el silencio en la mesa
lo que pasó fue lo siguiente de un lado
de la mesa habría alguien que me dijo
pero qué ignorante eres cómo puedes
decir eso cómo puedes hacer una
afirmación así en qué estás pensando
quién te crees es más quién lo invito
del otro lado de la mesa
hubo alguien que dijo interesante fíjate
que yo pienso como tú concuerdo con tu
punto de vista y por acá tendríamos a
alguien que se hizo la pregunta
que el libro habrá leído cuál es el
libro que leyó hace unos años que lo
impactó tanto y que lo llevó a esa
conclusión y porque él cree en ese libro
y el quién es que habrá estudiado de
dónde viene por qué está aquí y porque
además lo dice así sin más
bueno el libro que leí fue el gran
diseño del de stephen hawking publicado
en el 2010 en donde este gran científico
en donde este gran científico plantea
después de un gran estudio que no es
necesario invocar a dios para explicar a
la creación las leyes de la física se
explican por sí mismas la idea de un
creador del universo es innecesaria
ustedes imagínense la repercusión que
una afirmación así puede tener en el
mundo con los medios de opinión cómo
puede influir algo así en la humanidad
es una afirmación que en un momento dado
puede alertar poderes puede confrontar a
las instituciones pueden estar personas
enemistar las incluso a muerte lo vemos
todo el tiempo
pero si saltamos un poquito más atrás
encontramos otro caso
hace casi 400 años otro célebre
científico galileo galilei es muy
conocido publicaba sus estudios sobre
los cielos él no sólo había descubierto
el telescopio y había hecho
observaciones interesantísima sobre los
astros y sus movimientos sino que
reformuló la teoría de copérnico y
y atrevió a anunciar que el sol estaba
en el centro del universo y la tierra le
daba vueltas alrededor
esta visión heliocéntrica
fue una revelación no solo la tierra
giraba alrededor del sol sino todos los
planetas con ella por primera vez en
siglos y siglos de escrituras sagradas
nuestra ubicación en el espacio tenía
una nueva versión
en realidad no importaba lo que
copérnico dijera o lo que galileo dijera
sobre la posición del sol lo que
importaba es que contravenía al poder
absoluto contravenía a una verdad
dictada
ponía en riesgo el gran domo del status
quo
pero
personajes como galileo se atrevieron a
preguntarse más fueron más allá
dedicaron su vida
a buscar respuestas a un saliéndose de
la verdad dictada
aun poniendo su vida en riesgo su
libertad
y quién se preguntó quién sería galileo
por qué haría eso
galileo uno de los iniciadores de la
revolución científica en europa un gran
científico renacentista que cambiaría
influiría sobre la ciencia y sobre la
humanidad
voy a dar un salto de 200 años en el
tiempo mediados del siglo 19 encontramos
a otro gran científico en esta ocasión
es charles darwin valbuena está
publicando en este momento su máxima
obra el origen de las especies'
y darwin fue un poquito más osado su
versión es un poco más escandalosa por
dos razones porque contraviene la verdad
absoluta y porque pone en el centro de
la polémica al homo sapiens al hombre
lo que él dice con su teoría de la
evolución a través de la selección
natural y sexual de las especies es que
todos los animales y los seres vivos
descienden de una de un ancestro en
común evolucionaron con los años se
fueron transformando algunos
extinguieron y otros permanecen y el
homo sapiens es uno de ellos es un ser
vivo igual a todos los demás y tiene un
ancestro en común también un homínido
desciende de un homínido en pocas
palabras si darwin le estaba diciendo al
mundo que el ser humano desciende de un
árbol
y peor aún que es un chango es un
homínido si lo sigue siendo solo que es
pensante
esto fue un escándalo en ese momento
por primera vez alguien un científico
destronaba al ser humano de la cumbre de
la pirámide de los seres vivos le
quitaba su supremacía sobre todo el
reino natural y lo igualaba a todas las
especies
la verdad es que si yo hubiera estado
con darwin en la cena lo hubiera dejado
a él que hablara pues para por lo menos
llegar al postre
pero quién era darwin quien se preguntó
quién era el árbol porque es hacia eso
porque decía eso detrás de darwin en el
siglo 19 había un bagaje
un bagaje cultural muy importante que
venía empujando de siglos y siglos de
investigaciones
y le venía dictando y sumando
información para poder gracias
conclusiones un saltito más atrás atrás
de darwin unos 60 años hacia 1800
principios del siglo 19 otro gran
científico alexander von humboldt está
por iniciar su gran viaje histórico por
américa es la américa colonial es la
américa española
américa que está dividida en virreinatos
gobernada por virreyes
y organizada en una compleja compleja
sociedad de castas
humboldt llega acá y recorre los
territorios de los actuales países de
colombia venezuela perú ecuador y méxico
registra todas todas las cosas que
pueden navegar los ríos los lagos conoce
montañas registra especies animales
vegetales no sólo conoce el monte
chimborazo en sudamérica sino que acá en
méxico pasa por el nevado de toluca
incluso se asoma en las minas de
guanajuato que en aquel entonces eran
muy famosas por ser el máximo centro de
producción de riqueza del mundo
y hace como resultado de todos estos
registros él hace una aportación muy
interesante
el habla de que el mundo es una unidad
es uno solo
qué novedad
hoy en día eso nos parece muy simple
pero en aquel entonces esto tenía una
implicación muy interesante
como una unidad si es una unidad es un
sistema conformado por un muchos
ambientes y por seres vivos
interconectados y todos funcionan y
conviven en esta unidad
estos inquiete implicaciones tiene que
todas las continentes son iguales no hay
continentes mejores o peores
no hay continentes más nobles o menos
nobles el oxígeno es el mismo en
australia que en méxico las nubes pasan
igual por parís que en la patagonia no
hay diferencias la naturaleza es la
naturaleza esta idea en ese momento era
revolucionaria
no se pensaba así
y recomendó cuidar esa unidad
recomiendo cuidar el medio ambiente
protegerlo porque si se ha causada en un
lugar repercute en otro
pero qué pasa 200 años después en la
actualidad seguimos viendo y viendo
visiones confrontadas al respecto
tenemos evidencia suficiente que señala
que el calentamiento global es una
realidad que hemos afectado al planeta
de un modo irreversible y hay posturas
que no lo creen hay posturas que están
en contra de esta visión una vez más los
poderes se alertan las instituciones se
confrontan y las personas se enemistan
por ideas distintas
si regresamos con humbolt encontramos
algo más interesante él exploró a los
seres vivos y dentro de los seres vivos
están también las personas del ser
humano
pudo adentrarse en los confines de la
selva de los bosques gracias a los
nativos a los pueblos nativos de cada
región ellos lograron ellos lo ayudaron
entonces los conocidos y los conoció en
su entorno en todos los registros él
recomendó después
que todos los gobiernos deben de
proteger la diversidad de sus pueblos y
sus culturas deben de apoyarlos y deben
de ayudarlos a preservar sus tradiciones
sus culturas y sus lenguas
imagínense siglo 19
no sé qué cara habrá hecho el rey de
españa cuando yo esto
pero qué pasa doscientos años después en
el presente tenemos visiones encontradas
con situaciones similares una cantidad
de etnias y de gente que emigra de
centroamérica buscando el sueño
americano pasa por méxico
condiciones de vulnerabilidad quizás
desamparados y se suscita un debate de
gente a favor y gente en contra de esto
hay quienes ven en ello la necesidad de
ayudar y apoyarlos porque es una causa
humanitaria y hay quienes lo ven como un
desastre como algo molesto como algo que
afea el paisaje
me regreso con humble de nuevo humbolt
hablo de algo muy interesante también él
dijo que los seres vivos por naturaleza
tienen que vivir en libertad
merecen vivir en libertad merecen vivir
en su entorno libremente y eso incluye a
las personas a los seres humanos abogó
por la libertad de todas las personas
humble se fue de méxico en 1805 y tan
solo 10 años después
en 1810 hidalgo y morelos después
abogaban por estos mismos principios en
libertad en su gran lucha por la
independencia de mexico libertad equidad
e igualdad de derechos a hidalgo ya
morelos ni siquiera los hubieran dejado
sentarse en la mesa a cenar
incluso les costó la vida
y qué pasa
tienes humboldt humboldt no es un cometa
que aparece por ahí de la nada un ser
iluminado un científico
con muchos conocimientos que aparece y
desaparece no él también tiene un
momento histórico
él también fue influenciado por una
serie de acontecimientos antes que el
psuv alegó bagaje cultural es muy
interesante él es un noble español el
alemán perdón que vivió en europa
toda la gran odisea de la revolución
francesa
el vídeo de cerca la declaración
universal de los derechos humanos la
caída de la monarquía absoluta en
francia
el festejo la independencia de eeuu de
los ingleses y la instauración de la
primera democracia en américa cuando él
llega acá encuentra
el laboratorio perfecto en la américa
colonial para contrastar sus
conocimientos ese es un momento
histórico ese es el fútbol que piensa y
registra y expone sus cosas al mundo
como él siempre se pregunta un poco más
igual que los igual igual que los otros
que darwin que galileo que hopkins y que
todos los científicos siempre se
preguntó
cuál será más tarde la realidad siempre
quiso encontrar nuevas respuestas y yo
les recomiendo los invito a que hagamos
lo mismo nuestra vida cotidiana
preguntémonos más preguntémonos más
sobre las ideas distintas sobre las
cosas que nos parecen distintas a lo que
pensamos y lo que creemos porque son así
que son de dónde vienen de dónde
salieron
preguntarnos cuál es el momento
histórico del otro
créanme nos va a ayudar a entender mejor
todo
[Aplausos]